[Applaudissements]
pennsylvania avenue à washington était
plein à craquer ils sont venus des
quatre coins des états unis pour exiger
du changement regardez autour de vous
10e survivants de la tuerie de portland
nous sommes le changement nous ne
voulons plus de cette violence cris ces
jeunes américains au pied du congrès la
première tuerie à colombo est de trop
dit cette étudiante âgée de 15 ans nous
sommes au point de non retour
cette mobilisation monstre est l'oeuvre
d'étudiants écoeurés des tueries dans
les écoles leurs parents aussi n'en
peuvent plus et 9,19 à ces cétacés
déclare cette femme de détroit dont la
nièce a été tué par une arme à feu
[Musique]
plusieurs grandes vedettes de la musique
était là pour appuyer un meilleur
contrôle des armes
certains ont hurlé leur colère
[Musique]
d'autres comme emma gonzalez qui a vécu
la dernière fusillade en floride ont
choisi le silence
de longues minutes à ne rien dire devant
cette foule immense pour rappeler le peu
de temps qu'a pris le tueur pour
assassiner 17 personnes à la saint
valentin
cette enseignante venue de floride a été
bouleversé par la tuerie ce n'est pas
correct dit elle ce n'est pas normal
d'avoir peur d'aller à l'école
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cris les pleurs et les chants seront
ils suffisants cette fois pour
convaincre les politiciens wanderers
plusieurs en doute
mais ces jeunes n'entendent plus reculés
pour sauver des vies pour sauver leur
vie
[Applaudissements]